so interestingly blown up in the last
year yeah and the celebrity and all the
[__] that comes with it I mean I've
experienced it and I'm sure that were
you 26 yeah I'm 26. okay so there's a
lot changing for you right now you're
becoming a big deal how do you think
you're handling that yes very good
questions you know
um I would say at first
um it was actually not hard for me
um but I would say the bigger I've
gotten it's very hard being like
criticized over like every little thing
and especially from a lot of I found
reaction channels are really just like
looking to take you out of context or
they're just like and it's really not
fair because they're not live and it's
like they have pre-recorded edited stuff
so if they say anything dumb they can
just edit it out and you do long
episodes
correct and I do three sometimes I've
even done a five I've done a 24-hour
live stream are they gonna clip anything
that I said wrong in 24 hours hours and
hours of foot like you're gonna find
something and yeah obviously because you
are now foreign money people can be your
friend to get money people can insult
you to get money
that you are on the table nothing is off
limits now and I noticed um recently I
hope you don't mind me bringing this up
because I found it fascinating when I
first discovered you you had another
almost a co-host you well I um
bald-headed guy who was very articulate
very good speaker and I thought you guys
made a good team and he sort of um you
know disappeared from the channel he
then makes a video about you very
recently accusing you of being a
colonizer which I was like you know I'm
not really sure where he's coming from
this and and I watch this video does he
look like he has a gun to his head we've
actually got an editor in the room who
happens to also be a black man yeah um
so you know maybe this is evidence no
yeah he has a horrible life he looks
really happy right blessing it's
horrible
and look to summarize the video just for
people who haven't seen it give context
the guy um said look on the one hand uh
Pearl's knowledge of the history of
African struggles was very limited and I
had to educate her on how people
colonized he said he said schooled me he
schooled you yes and then he takes that
he takes that little footage he had of
him explaining something to you about
history yeah and then also then goes I
had a historian actually reached out to
me and say that he was wrong I don't
know I'm not going to quote it yeah but
I did have a historian like reach out to
me and say like what he said was
factually inaccurate and I was like well
I don't know the thing the thing that
made it strange was that he then linked
it to you then signing up uh content
creators and he basically he said you
know on the one hand she didn't know
anything about colonizing and on the
other hand she's trying to sign these
people up so therefore I mean she is a
she's a column and I was like look man
you're putting two and two together and
getting five here you're not even close
to the truth like she you are creating
an agency this is what uh you know this
is the industry that music and many many
of people are in with entertainment
people spot Talent they have a platform
to boost that talent and you're actually
helping people
um so I I felt like it was very salty
but it was for me watching you as a
younger Creator and blowing up I was
like this is what happens you know
people if they're not on the gravy train
they'll turn on you very quickly and I
thought it was a shame to see that
happen to you so young yeah no I was
very surprised by that video it was
funny I saw it scheduled earlier in the
day it said the truth about Pearl and I
thought it was going to be him vouching
for me oh no yeah no I
read I was on the Zone with my dad and I
was like Dad he wouldn't do that plus
he's like twice my age so I'm like he's
too old for this and then the video came
out I was like
what like when did yeah and um yeah that
was I was you were friends right okay I
thought he said we weren't friends but I
met his son so I was like why would you
bring your son to meet me if we weren't
friends yeah and then there was like
clips of him him insinuating like I
wanted something with him and I was like
no like what do you yeah and then then
the weirdest accusation
was the sexual whiteboard parties did
you see that at the end oh yeah where
the NP said is it it it basically
there's a cliffhanger which I was like I
mean I rate the creativity of it because
he made it look like you were guys were
having like orgies like [__] Playboy
Mansion sober at that point I was so mad
it was like um oh my gosh it was so
funny because one he put in videos of
two producers that like like um blessing
like he people know kind of know who he
is but he's not on camera and some
people don't want to be on camera so he
put people in that video that like
weren't a part of this you know and then
the funny thing was it was like the
tamest party ever it was um we gave
everybody the big whiteboard right and
we said you can do a speech on anything
and you know uh my speech was the ways
that men cap yeah because I was like I'm
always on on the whim and today I'm
switching teams you know yeah so I was
like today yeah and then he just took
that and like ran with it I guess well
he made it a race issue which I think
considering your channel is you know
it's from people from all backgrounds
consistently it just and I thought
you're gonna have to have some hard
evidence here and he had nothing no I I
don't know why he did that um I could I
could speculate but I I wish him well I
hope he you know the fact that you're so
gracious about it was surprising I hope
he does his thing I wish he didn't I was
a quite Rude video if I may say so
myself a lot of false accusations but I
mean yeah maybe in a few years they'll
be you'll be more uh prone to get a
lawyer out when those things happen I
don't know because that's how things
change unfortunately yeah I mean there
is some legal stuff going on but I can't
really talk too much about but yeah
we're on it you got banned from Tick
Tock right what was that for Homer has
five times wow I'll tell you the
original band I've just got on Tick Tock
so I bet I'll be aware of this yeah yeah
you can't call women
yeah yeah so my first go ahead I don't
care so my first um Tick Tock I almost
had to do a million followers because I
was on Tick Tock before YouTube that's
what I've kind of blown up on shorts
because I've done it before on Tick Tock
so when I went to YouTube I killed the
shorts game you know what I mean so
um on uh Tick Tock there was a video
that I call this the attack I've spoken
about this before so I'm doing my street
interviews and this lady who who's I'm
not gonna you know insult her and go up
about her looks but yeah so if I had to
if I had to use words we're talking
about security I'm walking home alone at
night and I just can't stand the women
that are like oh my God I can't walk
home alone at night I'm like okay
neither can nobody can you seem like you
would be fine the walking home alone I
think you might know like even you know
if there's enough people you're [__]
it doesn't matter how big you are right
yeah yeah
and likely to be victims of a violent
crime so I was just like nobody can walk
home alone at night like maybe this is
what I I was I'm solution minded so I
said why don't you just not live in a
big city that's dangerous and not walk
home alone and not I'm not I'm you know
what I live in the same city and there's
sometimes I don't walk home alone
because I'm scared and and she didn't
like this so she just started freaking
out and she's like I'll have you you
slag I'll have you now I didn't know
what a slag meant at the time okay
because I'm American so we don't use I
guess that's [__] is that right [__]
which I was like rude now and so because
she kept calling me a slag I was like
whatever you're and so because you've
said a lot to her yeah yeah but she
started it she called me a slag like you
know most of the time when I do call
these women they call me something first
I am I am responding I do say in
generalities I could probably cut back
on that but I think it's funny so I yeah
I keep doing it so anyway so this girl
came at me and then because I I when I
put the captions on this video they I
woke up my account was banned as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible